[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEPHANIE: I have the honor
of welcoming Katie Parla today
to Google.
Katie Parla is a food
and beverage educator
and a journalist.
She has been featured
in the "New York Times,"
"The Guardian," countless
food and travel publications.
She's written and
edited over 20 books,
including "Tasting
Rome," which she'll be
signing for those of you today.
And she's actually
in the Bay Area
working on a new cookbook
about Southern Italy.
I'm most excited to have
Katie here, because she
is my personal hero.
She is someone who has
found passions in her life
and has built a life and career
around those passions, namely
Roman food and drink.
So very excited to
have her here today,
so please join me in welcoming
Katie Parla to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
KATIE PARLA: That was so kind.
I have really high
cholesterol, so it's
the product of eating
lots of carbonara
on all of your behalves.
And so don't be-- note
you're here on the health
sense of the word.
But I am really excited, because
15 years ago, I moved to Rome,
and somehow managed
to sort of craft
a career talking
about food and drink.
And my path started to veer
towards food and beverage
at a super young
age, so I was sort of
naturally attracted
to these things
growing up in New Jersey.
And although I went to Rome
originally for art history
reasons, I was almost
instantly distracted
by pizza, pasta, wine, and
later, Italian craft beer.
So Stephanie, thanks so
much for inviting me today.
I'm so psyched to see
all you guys out here.
And hey, livestream people.
So the city of Rome--
well, if we trust
Roman sources--
was founded on
April 21st, 753 BC,
a date for which there is
zero archaeological evidence
but is celebrated.
If you visit Rome on the
21st of April next year,
you'll find all sorts of
historical re-enactors
marching down Via dei Foro
Imperiali doing all these
really bizarro
reenactments in the Circus
Maximus and these areas that
legend tell us were developed
27 centuries ago.
Archeology says the cities look
a little bit older than that.
But what this sort of tension
between myth and history shows
us, and something that repeats
over and over in Roman culture,
is that Romans love to craft
their own notion of themselves,
and they market their
food accordingly.
So we're going to be talking
about the history of Roman food
today.
I want to talk to you about
some of the ingredients
and techniques that are typical.
You're going to start
seeing a lot of those things
aren't native to
Rome, but they're
the product of people
coming from all over Italy
and, indeed, all over
the world and creating
this really wonderfully
contaminated cuisine.
The photo on the left
shows the Roman Forum.
I'm standing-- when I'm
shooting this photo,
I'm standing on mint
and mallow and arugula.
These all grow wild
all over the city.
These are some of the
millennial flavors
of Rome, things that people
have had in their foods
and now even to a greater
extent in their digestive
liqueurs for a very long time.
And in the background,
you have some
of the ruins of a first
century warehouse,
and then even further
beyond, the magnificent ruins
of the Tabularium and
temples in the Forum.
In the very far distance
is the Vittoriano,
and although maybe
on another date,
I'll talk to you about the 27
centuries before unification.
But today I really want to focus
on Italian unification, so 1870
when Rome becomes
the capital to today,
and how the food developed
and continues to evolve.
So at the top, you see
what some people in Rome
call the national calamity.
Others, the typewriter
or the wedding cake.
It goes by other
names-- the altar
of the fatherland,
the Vittoriano,
and it's name for
Victor Emmanuel
II, so the king of
Italy, who claimed
Rome as his capital in
1870 after this massive
philosophical and
military battle
to unite disparate cultures
under a unified crown.
The monument obstructs
the view of the Forum
really, taking over
the center of town
and asserting this new
regime and its presence,
but, of course, plucking
different images from Roman
culture, so lots of marble
reliefs and sculptures
and things that evoke antiquity.
When Victor Emmanuel II
came to Rome in 1870,
there were 150,000
people in town.
That number grew to about
1.4 million by 1935,
and so in that
interim period, one
of the major responsibilities
of both the national
as well as the local
governments was
to streamline the food system.
So how do you feed
all these people?
By the way, the huge
increase in population
was not the product of Romans
being very amorous and fertile.
It was, in fact, the
product of people
leaving, especially
the south of Italy
and rural places in Tuscany,
Le Marche, the Veneto,
and going to Italian
cities, especially Rome.
This is also the time that many
people of the south of Italy
and came to United States.
And so you have all of
these different influences
coming from the
north and the south
and converging on
the Italian capital,
bringing their food techniques
with them, their ingredients.
We'll talk a little
bit about that.
The government created all
sorts of these major food
spaces like in the bottom,
that black and white photo,
the Mattatoio, or
the slaughterhouse.
So when I moved to
Rome 15 years ago,
I imagined that
I would find lots
of farmers selling the things
directly to the people.
This is actually a market
very close to the Vatican.
In about 1925,
you could actually
go get freshly plucked chickens
or recently slaughtered lambs.
But now the food supply has
really, really transformed,
and that's the
product of the Mercati
Generali and the Mattatoio.
These are the two
major food halls.
The Mercati Generali was where
a lot of produce would come in,
so the government wanted
to elongate the food supply
or elongate the
supply chain in order
to generate all sorts
of jobs along the way.
This is one way to build
employment in the capital.
And this sprawling complex that
employed thousands of people
and fed hundreds of thousands
of people at its peak
was built on a flood plain in
the southern part of the city,
so the Ostiense district.
If you've ever seen
that pyramidal tomb
next to the Lido
station, it's just
past that very close to Eataly.
The Mercati Generali
was where farmers
would bring in their goods,
and then this wholesale market
is where goods would be
distributed to businesses,
restaurants, and markets.
Eventually, this huge
complex became surrounded
by the metro area of Rome.
And so that complex has
now been moved further away
from the city, and this
is a general custom.
The wholesale markets move
further and further away
from the center of town, which
really reduces the access
to food and sort of
limits ingredients, which
we'll talk about momentarily.
This is what the Mercati
Generali looks like today.
The building is this
sort of wonderful example
of decaying urban archeology.
It is, I guess, for
trespassers only.
Sometimes you'll see
people tagging up
the complex, which
sprawled over thousands
and thousands of square
meters and now is
in different states of repair.
The current plan is
to transform this
into a cultural and shopping
like Xanadu of sorts,
and that is a work in progress.
They were in progress
when I moved to Rome
a decade and a half ago.
This is more or less what
the place looks like now.
So maybe in a few
years we'll know more.
So while produce went
into the Mercati Generali
and then was distributed
to restaurants
and to marketplaces, animals
would come in, instead,
to Testaccio, which is not
far from the Mercati Generali.
Testaccio now is a really
popular destination
for eating all sorts
of carnivorous dishes,
a lot of offal dishes.
And the real predominance
of organ meats and poor cuts
that you find in the restaurants
and home tables of Testaccio
is indebted to
the slaughterhouse
being in operation in that
neighborhood from 1888
to about 1970.
And this is a really,
again, sprawling complex
that was built in
the unification era
in order to really streamline
a food system to feed
lots and lots of people.
Now when you're slaughtering
thousands of animals a week
and discarding various
parts of their bodies
into the Tiber River, this
generates a less than appealing
set of olfactory experiences.
So as Trastevere was
developing on the other side
of the river, not the beautiful
medieval part, of course,
but the 1960s
development, it started
to become a hygienic issue
to have all this slaughter
happening in town.
So just like the Mercati
Generali moved out of town, so,
too, did the Mattatoio,
or the slaughterhouse.
And it starts to be repurposed
after a period of decay,
and today, you can walk through
the ruins of the ex-Mattatoio,
this former slaughterhouse, and
find modern art installations,
the area and southern
part has been turned
into an organic supermarket.
There is a cafe.
There's like a fixie bike shop.
There's a university
department for the University
of Rome's architecture school.
So actually, in the halls
where the tripes used
to be harvested from
grazing animals,
you can sit in on lectures
about architectural development,
which is kind of spectacular.
So this is a great example of
how food spaces, decayed food
spaces are now being repurposed.
So where do people shop?
How do people get their food?
There are two main sources.
The majority of Romans
shop at supermarkets,
but we have, especially people
skewing towards the older
end of the demographic spectrum,
go to the Mercati Rionali.
So there are about 125
of these markets in Rome.
This is the Nomentano
Market, which
was built during
the fascist era,
has these really
wonderful sort of almost
basilica-like aisled halls
with light streaming in,
and each of these
stalls is often
staffed by middlemen
who go to the Mercati
Generali or its analog,
and then resell produce.
So these aren't
farmers' markets,
but there is this custom in
Rome of going to the markets
and purchasing things
that are from Italy.
Now in the past seven years
or so, since about '09, now we
have a lot of farm direct
sales in specific markets.
So some farmers
lobbied the government
in order to sell
directly to the consumer.
So if you visit the Trionfale
Market near the Vatican,
you'll find these
green banners that
announce that the produce
is coming from a farm,
often in Rome, not, perhaps,
next to the Colosseum,
but certainly not far.
And it's a 20-minute
drive from that market
to the field from which the
artichoke is so beautifully
pruned or plucked.
Supermercati are another
source of shopping for people.
This is the Eataly supermarket.
The largest in the world
is actually in Rome.
It's about three and
1/2 times the size
of the Chicago or the
New York locations,
and so Despar or Eataly or any
of these larger supermarket
chains often draw from
some of the visuals
of the local markets, especially
in the hanging prosciutti
and cappocoli and
all of these things
to create atmosphere, where
the goods are actually
sold from the refrigerated
case, as the law requires.
So we've got a little bit
of a historical basis.
What is Roman food?
It is vastly different than
the food of Venice or Florence
or even Frosinone or Latino,
which are cities near Rome.
Roman cuisine is the product of
its ingredients, its geography.
Rome is located 13
miles from the sea
and 13 miles from
former volcanoes
with very rich soil, which
have historically grown grapes
and all sorts of produce.
It's divided by a river,
and we talked a bit
about the spontaneous
greenery that you
find in Rome-- mint and all of
these sort of like herbaceous
greens that can be
used to flavor foods.
So in antiquity, Romans
may have eaten lamb
and had lots of local greens,
but in the 20th century,
we saw the arrival
of dried pasta,
especially from the area
around Gragnano, Naples,
so when you visit
a Roman restaurant,
you find pasta shapes
like spaghetti,
rigatoni, pasta that's
extruded through bronze dye,
dried slowly, boiled, and
dressed with condiments.
But you can find that all over.
Those shapes are available
in all of Italy's regions.
What's really typical of
Rome are potato gnocchi.
Potatoes, of course,
come from the New World
but are introduced to the
southern Italian peninsula
in the 1500s, and
then sort of absorbed
throughout the
succeeding centuries.
And in Rome, potato gnocchi
are a Thursday dish,
so we don't need
them on Wednesday.
We don't eat them on Friday.
We eat them on Thursdays
for a specific reason.
I've been talking
all about Rome,
but there's another really
important nation in that part
of Italy-- the Vatican.
And so the Catholic calendar
influences some of the things
that we eat on certain days,
and Friday, being a lean day,
it's a day that you
really want to prepare
for, ideally with a
caloric potato-rich pasta,
so potato gnocchi are
a Thursday tradition
as a direct result of this.
Another great calorie
source that we enjoy in Rome
is guanciale, cured pork jowl.
This is used as a fat source.
It's also a flavor source
for our classic pastas--
amatriciana, carbonara, gricia.
Although we're so close
to the sea, we don't--
well, historically, we haven't
eaten a lot of fresh fish
in Rome.
Now since the '60s onwards,
people have refrigeration.
Ice is readily available.
But before that, people relied
on salted fish, specially
salted cod, baccala coming
from the north of Europe,
sometimes processed in
the north of Europe,
other times processed
in Compiano or Calabria,
and then salted anchovies.
The river perch, the
eel the sturgeon,
catfish, all these Tiber
fish are really not
consumed in any
significant way any longer.
So if you were looking for any
of those things on Roman menus,
you're not going to find them.
Sorry.
The sort of symbol of
Rome is the artichoke,
and carciofo is the
Italian word for artichoke.
The artichokes that we have
that are growing locally
are called carciofi romaneschi.
Similarly, our pale green
strident zucchini are zucchine
{} romanesche, and so things
that are highly local are given
the adjective to define
their provenance,
although I would footnote that
artichokes are probably from
coming into Rome from the
south of Italy in the 1500s,
and zucchini arrive
from the New World.
So there is this custom of
adopting things from elsewhere
and giving them a
Roman name in order
to provide them with a
sense of authenticity.
Pecorino Romano is an
ancient type of cheese.
The way that it's
produced now is now
defined by 20th
century law, but Romans
have been salting
sheep's milk cheese
and aging it for millennia.
The byproduct of
cheese production
is all this very protein-rich
whey, which can be reheated
and sort of coagulated proteins
can be skimmed off and drained
to make a ricotta, which
is often, obviously,
sheep's milk ricotta, because
there's so much sheep's milk
cheese.
Lambs still graze near Rome.
If you're like an avid
runner, I recommend
starting in the Circus Maximus,
running down the Appian Way
through the Caffarella Park
on your next trip to Rome,
and the earth gets
softer and softer
as you move outside
the city center
and get all of these
beautiful grazing
lands, where sheep are grazed.
And it's really, really
lovely, a reminder that Rome
was a really rural city
until quite recently,
and you still do find
these pockets of rural life
throughout town.
The pork tradition in Rome
is an ancient one as well,
though our sort of
dominant pork ingredient
is the guanciale that
I referenced earlier.
Offal, so things like heart,
lungs, liver, trachea stew,
AKA coratella, tripe
simmered in a tomato sauce--
really classic Roman dishes--
and mint, pepperoncino, and
salt are our main seasonings.
So a lot of what I've been
sort of discussing today
is derived from library
research and archival research,
but let's get into the streets.
These are things that you'll
actually encounter in Rome,
especially if you are staying
around the Prati district
or Trionfale district,
which has really
become a hub for street
food and different types
of traditional foods in Rome.
So street food and
fast food are foods
that are consumed on the fly.
Street food might be a
little bit of a misnomer,
because we don't have a
lot of food trucks in Rome
like you guys have out here.
Street food, or strit fud
as we sometimes say in Rome,
spelled S-T-R-I-T F-U-D--
I'm not kidding.
It's a real thing.
Street food is often consumed
at brick and mortar places, so
rather than going to a
little food truck, which
for a variety of legal reasons
is a little bit complicated
to set up a business like that.
We go to a pizza al
taglio spot, a pizza
by the slice place,
which often has
slices of pizza and fried rice
balls and all of these things
that you can eat and
that are portable
and that are, above
all, are cheap.
There's this myth
that Romans sit down
to long luxurious
lunches lasting hours
and that we start
with an antipasto
and then move on to a pasta and
a main course and a vegetable
side dish and then dessert, and
this is all fueled with wine.
And then it's punctuated
by dessert and amaro.
I mean that's a
holiday meal, but it's
a ritual that is so
long, takes so long, it's
impractical in the modern
day business rhythms.
And it's, above all,
far too expensive
for most Roman residents.
So we ate a lot of
food on the fly,
and pizza al taglio
is a Roman classic.
So visit Florence or Naples,
you might find Roman style pizza
by the slice, but this is really
an indigenous mid-20th century
food that we consume daily.
Well, at least I do.
But remember, I have very
high cholesterol, so not
the best to follow my diet.
There are these sort
of canonical pasta
dishes in Rome--
carbonara, gricia, amatriciana
being sort of consolation
that's related to
gricia as the base.
So has anyone had gricia?
Yeah, awesome.
Cool.
So gricia is essentially
the pasta dish
upon which amatriciana
and carbonara are based,
so you've got pasta, black
pepper, Pecorino, guanciale,
some people put garlic in it,
some people put onion in it.
There are very
passionate debates
about whether this
should be allowed.
In essence, there are no
original gricia recipes,
and some people have
sort of freestyled
based on the sort
of flavor profile
that they're looking for.
But generally speaking, it's
those sort of building blocks
that I mentioned.
So pasta, guanciale, black
pepper, Pecorino Romano,
and the sort of fat source there
is the rendered guanciale fat.
It provides not just
fat, but also flavor.
If you add egg to this,
the product is carbonara.
If you add tomato instead,
the product is amatriciana.
And although there
is a very long
and another passionate
debate about the origins
of amatriciana, the
town of Amatrice
claims to be the
birthplace of this dish.
In fact, the first
recorded recipes
that we have of a
amatriciana is actually
gricia, a tomato-less
pasta dish.
Cacio e pepe is related in
sort of the salty Pecorino
aspect and the fact that it
does have black pepper in it.
But this is a separate
food altogether.
It is not related to gricia
or carbonara or amatriciana.
It was drunk food.
This is the food that you would
eat after a long alcohol-fueled
meal, like in the pre-'50s
era, when Romans would go out,
and food was cheap, and you
could eat and drink for many
hours.
And after dessert,
you would drink more
and continue drinking.
And you would need something
to soak up all the alcohol.
There's this really
wonderful place
in the center of Rome
called Armando al Pantheon,
and this place used to be
sort of like half trattoria,
casual dining area,
half tavern, and cacio
e pepe wasn't on their menu.
You would order
it after dessert,
after all your wine was done
so that you could stumble home
without sort of feeling ill.
Soak up the-- mac and
cheese soaks up booze,
like this is not a
revolutionary idea.
And this sort of pasta dish
is along the same lines
as aglio e olio,
peperoncino, spaghetti
with garlic, chili, and oil.
Now in the post '50s era,
both aglio olio, peperoncino,
and cacio e pepe have
merged and are now
sort of welcome into the
pasta canon on the home
table and the restaurant table.
Often, we sort of separate
the cucina ebraica
or the Jewish tradition of Rome
when we talk about Roman food,
and, in fact, it, of course,
follows the laws of kashrut,
so no guanciale.
None of the dishes
combine dairy and meat,
but there are a lot of
similarities in the Roman
Jewish tradition with respect
to the flavor profiles
and ingredients of
the Roman tradition.
Jews arrived in Rome in
the second century, BC.
There are now around
13,000 Jews in Rome.
A small number of
these are logically
descended from the first
arrivals of free Jews
during the republic,
but now we also
have this really rich,
small but very rich
Jewish culture in Rome.
Remember that in 1492, Jews were
expelled from Spanish dominion.
That included the
south of Italy.
So imagine Jews being expelled
from Calabria, Sicily,
and fleeing either to
Rome or to the Balkans,
bringing a lot of their
cooking traditions with them.
This dish is called concia.
In the south of Italy, it's
called zucchine alla scapece.
So it's basically
fried zucchini that's
been marinated in garlic
and basil or mint,
depending on your
preference, with vinegar.
And this is the most
classic Roman Jewish dish.
Perhaps globally, the twice
fried artichoke, carciofo alla
giudia is the most famous,
but in the local Roman
Jewish tradition, concia
is far more prevalent
and sort of defines
the very strong flavors
and seasonal vegetal aspects
of this local cuisine.
In 1967, the Roman
Jewish community
was enriched by the arrival
of around 4,000 Jews
from mainly Benghazi,
Tripoli, Misrata,
refugees escaping
pogroms in North Africa.
About half of the
refugees stayed, and now
a significant portion
of Rome's 13,000 Jews
are, in fact, of Libyan descent.
So if you visit the
Jewish ghetto, which
is the historical district,
about four city blocks
today, where Roman Jews were
confined to a squalid slum
by order of the pope, you'll
find a lot of the menus feature
concia and carciofo
alla giudia, but also
grouper or other white flaky
fish simmered with spices
and served with couscous.
There are phyllo pastries
soaked in syrup, things
that would be quite at home
on a North African table,
and, indeed, they were until
the Libyan community, which
is called the
comunita tripolina,
escaped and landed in Rome.
Quinto quarto.
Does anyone recognize the
like little ring up there,
in the foreground?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
KATIE PARLA: Hm?
KATIE PARLA: Nailed
it, intestine.
Specifically, it's the intestine
of a milk fed Veal that still
has its mother's milk inside.
When you simmer the intestines
and the milk together,
the milk-- don't make that face.
[LAUGHING] The milk makes a
sort of curdled creamy ricotta
like substance,
and it beautifully
pairs with rigatoni, because
the rigatoni are basically
the same diameter
as the intestines.
I'm getting so hungry
just thinking about this.
And you simmer the
intestines that
have been sort of cut into
segments and tied into rings,
and you cook those
in tomato sauce.
And then, of course,
season with salty Pecorino.
It's called pajata, and rigatoni
pajata is a Roman classic.
And it's not just pajata that
defines the quinto quatro,
or the offal tradition of
Rome, but tripe Roman style,
which denotes tripe,
honeycomb tripe in particular,
simmered in tomato
sauce, seasoned
with Pecorino and mint.
Coratella, which I
referenced earlier,
heart, lungs, liver,
and trachea that
are diced up and cooked with or
without artichokes, depending
on the season.
Our artichokes are in
season from February
until about April, May.
And Romans eat a
lot of fried food.
It's almost sacrilegious
to extract this
from the sort of
starters section,
or the sort of
street food section,
because so much of our
street food is deep fried.
But fried food is
something that we consume
at every festive meal,
whether it's battered
and fried vegetables, or
floured and fried zucchini,
all sorts of
croquettes, especially
rice croquettes suppli--
so rissoto balls
breaded and fried--
and, in the center of it
all, the carciofi alla
giudia that I
referenced earlier.
So although this talk and
the cookbook, "Tasting Rome,"
break things down
into segments, there
is so much overlap between
these categories in the Roman
tradition.
So tradition and evolution.
We've seen the sort of
classic ingredients,
lots of meat and awful, and the
seasonings like pepperoncino,
Pecorino-- which, although it's
a cheese, it's a seasoning.
It brings a lot of salty,
savory flavor to Roman foods.
The Cucina Romana as a
defined series of dishes
is constantly an evolution.
We didn't have carbonara
in Rome in the 1940's.
Now it is one of the
symbols of the city,
and so you have all
these dishes and customs
that are slowly introduced
and then absorbed in them
become part of the canon.
Well, there are
other things that
are now coming into the canon.
This sort of stack
of fried disks
is what I call nduja in carozza.
Mozzarella en carrozza is
like the classic snack food.
It's basically like battered
bread with mozzarella
and little anchovy
or anchovy paste.
Super, super savory.
So, in this case,
you've got mozzarella
that becomes like the
bread, and then nduja, which
is a spicy Calabrian salami,
that becomes a sort filling,
then it's breaded and fried.
And this was invented
by Gabrielli Bonacci,
one of the premier food
artisans and innovators in Rome.
And it's an acknowledgement in
the form of the spicy Calabrian
salami nduja that not
every Roman is from Rome.
In fact, there are
450,000 Calabrians
in Rome, which is a pretty
significant portion of the 4.3
million residents.
You'll see like a little--
frying is a bit of a theme here.
Suppli, for about a
century, were sort of
defined as a risotto
with meat sauce,
packed around some
mozzarella, deep fried.
So you get the sort of
melty mozzarella heart.
Food innovators like Stefano
Calagari and Gabrielli Bonacci,
and others, decided
like, what if we
put different
stuff in the rice--
and make the suppli,
which is this egg shaped
parcel that everyone
will immediately
recognize from the
outside, but when
you break it open
there's something
interesting inside,
in this case,
porchetta with frascati wine,
a nod to the Costelli Romani.
It's just southeast
of Rome, where
you find a lot of
porchetta makers,
and the village of
Frascati is located.
If you have one
bite in Rome, let
it be the brisket
sandwich at Mordi e Vai.
Those are the hands
of Sergio Esposito.
He opened his stall in the
Testaccio market in July 2012.
It was the hottest day
of the year that year.
Imagine Romans walking past
this hot meat sandwich stall
and just being repulsed by
the idea of eating a hot meat
sandwich.
So it took them a little bit
of time to build a clientele,
but he started giving away
little bits of his simmered
brisket-- brisket which is now
almost completely vanished from
Roman tables--
used to be a specialty
of his family.
He grew up the son of a
butcher based on in Testaccio.
He grew up in the
Testaccio Market,
and then went to work in
the organ's department
at the mattatoio,
slaughterhouse.
And as an employee of
the slaughterhouse,
he and his family had access
to a lot of poor cuts.
And that included
brisket, of course.
Now, he simmers brisket
with lots of aromatics,
and then puts it on a sandwich.
This is a radical innovation
by Roman standards.
Dishes like tripe
or brisket or pajata
would be served in a
defined way, on a plate,
at home, or at a restaurant.
The idea of having a
portable version of that
was a huge break with tradition.
But leave it to Sergio Esposito,
who is like 80 years old,
to make this really bold
decision to change the way
that we eat.
In 2009, we see the beginning of
this horrible financial crisis.
People can't afford to go out.
They start cutting corners
when it comes to food purchases
at home.
So Sergio, who's actually
retired at the time,
starts thinking about how he
can come out of retirement.
He was super depressed,
not talking to people,
not interacting with people.
So he and his wife opened
this stall in 2012.
But when you see a lot
of these fast food,
street food stalls opening
to provide Roman flavors
repackaged in a way that is
so respectful of tradition
and so much a part of the
natural flow and evolution
of dishes and his stall-- which
is box 85 at the Testaccio
Market--
now is packed, even during
the so-called Lucifer heatwave
that we had.
You couldn't get near the place.
People are all about
hot sandwiches,
even in July in Rome now.
The Trapizzino.
Tramezzino is triangular
sandwich made with white bread
with the crust cut off-- pizza.
So when you combine the name
tramezzino and the word pizza,
you get trapizzino.
It's pizza stuffed with things.
In this case, tongue with
green sauce in the middle--
green sauce is this
very herbal parsley
sauce with garlic, capers,
anchovies-- really typical
of Piedmont.
So this is a reminder
that the King of Italy
came from Piedmont in 1870.
And it's dressed over
this beautifully seasoned
simmered tongue.
And so here again, you've got
this Roman pizza innovation
or sandwich innovation that
merges an accepted form--
the pizza by the slice--
with local flavors.
And it makes a really
portable, really inexpensive,
new packaging for Roman food.
So let's end on a bitter note.
Cocktails used to be
really limited in Rome.
Certainly, when I first
started visiting in the '90s,
you could get a mojito
or a caipirinha.
There were a lot
of liquor companies
that were investing
in Roman nightlife.
But in 2009, a team of Romans--
after spending time in
the Caribbean and Mexico,
Northern Europe--
decided to create this
new space for cocktails,
one that, at first, was modeled
on London and New York cocktail
culture.
It was called the
Jerry Thomas Project.
So the first
celebrity bartender.
Pre-prohibition is
the namesake there.
And then, over the course
of the past several years,
the team behind the Jerry
Thomas Project has started to,
not just acknowledge,
but really invest
in the bitter flavors
that define the spirits
tradition of Central Italy.
So there's a lot of amaro,
all sorts of herbal infusions.
They now are involved in a
distillery in Piedmont that
makes very classic
turn-of-the-20th century
cordials and aperitifs
and even vermouths.
And so at the Jerry
Thomas Project
today, you might have
to knock on the door
and have to do the
whole speakeasy
thing that's very familiar
to you guys in the Bay Area.
But the flavors in the glass
are fully Italian, fully Roman.
So thank you guys so much.
I'm happy to answer any
questions that you have.
SPEAKER: So we have
a question from Luke.
Italians are increasingly
concerned about long term
residents in places like
Rome's historic center being
pushed out by Airbnb
and similar services.
What should be done about it?
And what can well-meaning
American tourists
do to be part of the solution?
KATIE: That is such
a good question.
I can provide an anecdotal
response to this.
Rome's historic center
before Airbnb was--
it was really dis-inhabited.
And I don't recall
the exact figure,
but I think somewhere
between like a quarter--
or maybe even up to a 1/3 of the
real estate was not lived in--
but instead was possessed
by family groups that
for a variety of
inheritance laws and things
might have disproportionate
shares of the apartment
ownership and might not
agree what to do with it.
So many families
I know today have
agreed that they do want the
income that Airbnb allows them.
And in a complex
economy, a little bit
of extra money flowing into
Roman pockets is appreciated.
There are a lot of
legal problems in Rome
about this and tax issues.
And I know that the
discussion will be ongoing.
But I would say when it comes
to what some people think
is like the controversial
Airbnb economy,
I would say stay
outside of the center.
Rome's historical center
is, from an area standpoint,
10% of the city or less.
Stay in neighborhoods like the
Ostiense district, Trionfale,
where your presence isn't
going to be contributing
to the degradation
of neighborhoods.
I used to live in Monte.
I couldn't get out of that
neighborhood fast enough,
because it was
purely Airbnb B and
tourist-oriented businesses.
What I do love is
that many people--
and I suggest this when people
contact me on Twitter or via
my website--
stay in Testaccio or stay
in Southern Trastevere
away from all the
tourists, if you really
want to be in Trastevere or
stay in Monteverde Vecchio
So you're close to the
center, but you're also
close to markets.
And you can contribute to
the local economy by cooking.
And I've got a lot of resources
on how you can purchase
from people rather
than corporations, when
it comes to doing food
shopping and things like that.
SPEAKER: There's a great food
market in Monteverde Vecchio,
which is really convenient.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned that
the whole pasta course followed
by the main course thing isn't
really what people do everyday
anymore.
Do restaurants still
assume that people do,
because I still see many
is organized that way?
KATIE: Great
question-- menus still
are structured in the anti
pasto, primo, secondo,
cantorno, dolce order, but
restaurants in the center
and beyond the center
both acknowledge
that Romans and visitors
alike are not going
to eat all of those courses.
And there are few signals
that demonstrate that.
Now, when you make a booking
at a Roman restaurant,
you have to tell them
what time you're coming--
used to just say, I'm going
to be at whatever [ITALIAN]
at 8PM.
And now, you have
to say 7:30 or 9:30.
So they acknowledge that locals
and visitors are both spending
less time at the table.
They're definitely buying less
wine, lingering shorter amount
of time.
And the pasta
portions have grown,
and this is not just
in the tourist centers,
but everywhere.
Let's say pre-2006, 2007, the
pasta portions at restaurants
were like 65 to 85 grams.
Now, there are 125 to
150 grams, because people
need to fill tables
at the restaurants.
So many restaurant
owners have started
to grow the portions
that they know
people are going to
invest in and that
provide them a larger margin--
more margin on a big plate
of pasta than on a big steak.
SPEAKER: Somewhat
related-- for folks
who are going to Rome, what
would be the perfect dinner?
Where would you go?
What would you order?
KATIE: OK, so can I say
the whole perfect day?
OK.
SPEAKER: Yes, please.
KATIE: I would start with
coffee at Sciascia in Prati.
I would go over to
the Trionfale Market
and do a little shopping there.
That's, by the way, just three
blocks north of the Vatican
but a profoundly Roman district
not destroyed by tourism.
It's really wonderful.
I would have a slice of pizza,
potato pizza with mozzarella
at Pizzarium.
And then, head over
to Panificio Bonci
for either a tomato filled
with rice or roasted chicken--
both really, really
excellent at that bakery
still in the Trionfale district.
I would then go to the gym
and go for a cocktail at Litro
in Monteverde Vecchio, before
heading to dinner at Cesare al
Casaletto where I would have all
the fried starters and pajata
and I would have
the figatelli, which
are the roasted pork livers.
And then, I would go
for an amaro at Roscioli
back in the center of Rome.
SPEAKER: One more
question from the Dory,
you've busted the myth
that Romans are all
devoted to local produce.
California cuisine started
with chefs like Alice Waters,
importing the Italian
and French tradition
of fresh local ingredients.
Is it time for Italy
to re-import this?
Any tips for finding high
quality local ingredients
in Rome?
KATIE: The economy
is complicated now.
And the way that supermarkets
and big box places like Italy
have managed to make
certain food systems really
efficient for those
larger businesses
has undermined the
economic stability
of the local marketplace.
In 09', we started to have
our first farmers markets.
Now, in the center of Rome,
we have almost no farmer's
markets.
It was just something
that wasn't sustainable.
Farms weren't able
to really do business
in a way that
justified them spending
their weekends in the
[SPEAKING ITALIAN],, which
is where there was really
a wonderful market.
I have a lot of
resources on where
you can go to purchase
awesome local produce,
but I would say the
Trionfale Market is
the best, most concentrated
number of farmers
that have direct sales.
The southern part of the market,
close to the fishmongers,
has a couple of
dozen farmers stalls
labeled with those
big green banners
that let you know this
is vendita diretta--
direct sale of produce.
Places like La Tradizione
for Italian cheeses--
Romans haven't really embraced
their local cheese production.
A place like Dol
di Origine Laziale
is one really amazing place
that acknowledges that Lazio
has really wonderful food.
Whereas, if you inquired another
deli, they'll be like oh,
no one wants
anything from Lazio.
What about something
from Emilia Romagna?
Is it time for Rome and
other parts of Italy
to start focusing on local,
seasonal, sustainable things
again?
Yeah, but it's a very expensive
endeavor by Rome standards.
I don't know the
Romans statistics,
but the average Italian
family spends 400 euros--
a little bit more--
412 euros a month on groceries
for a family of three.
That may not seem like a
lot in Bay Area figures,
but that is a huge
amount in terms
of Italian or Roman incomes.
There are lots of urban
gardens, especially
affiliated with more
left-wing political groups,
especially in urban areas
that have been systematically
disregarded by the local
governments of Rome--
the various municipalities.
So that's another way to
rejuvenate those things.
But until the city itself, which
is really involved in the food
system, starts investing
in food spaces that
are accessible to everyone,
I'm not super optimistic
that there's going to be a huge
Alice Water-style revolution.
We do have an Alice
Water-style revolution in Rome.
It's called the Rome
Sustainable Food Project.
It's really unusual for
Rome because the kitchen,
which is in the
American Academy,
is mostly teaching kitchen.
Most of the people that
work in there are interns.
A lot of them actually
come from Chez Panisse
or are destined
for Chez Panisse.
And all of the food
that is cooked there
comes from a really
small number of farms.
And maximum distance
is like 150 miles.
Some of the things
come from Tuscany,
but most everything
is coming from Lazio.
It's so expensive
to source things
locally, that it takes
a well-funded benefactor
to do something like that.
And take a walk around Rome in
the morning, like at 10:00 AM.
There's a ton of frozen
food truck traffic.
It's cheaper to have junk.
AUDIENCE: I'm originally
from Rome and sometimes--
Chao!
And sometimes, my
American friends
ask me what's the
dish from Rome?
I struggle to answer
that question,
because there's so
much that I like.
What would your answer be?
KATIE: What's the Roman dish is
such a hard question to answer,
because I think it depends
on the time of year.
If your friends are
going in August,
you probably don't want to
tell them to eat carbonara,
because then they will
dislike you afterwards.
It will be really uncomfortable
to eat that heavy food.
But I think that there
are a set of dishes.
I'll tell you my five bites.
You have to have a pasta
dish, so like cacio
e pepe or carbonara at
a place like Roscioli.
Pizza by the slice is as
Roman as any other dish.
So for a really classic
one, Aintoco Forno Roscioli,
or for like a more
evolved one, Pizzarium.
That brisket sandwich at the
Trionfale Market is amazing.
Some offal, either
pajata or figatelli
tripe at Cesare al Casaletto.
And then, a gelato--
that's a meal-- come on.
Um, by the way, my website
has all these resources
like top pastas.
If you only want eat pizza--
let's say your friends only
care about pizza-- there's
the Lucky Peach Pizza Guide.
Just warn them-- bring
their Lipitor or whatever
cholesterol-busting medication
they have access to.
But yeah, I see Rome
really as a combination
of different types of foods.
And if you're just
going to restaurants,
you're only getting
a small fraction
of what the city has to offer.
AUDIENCE: I had just
one other question.
That's more like a
selfish question.
It's hard here in the US
to find some products--
or at least in an
affordable way--
I'm just thinking five
slices of prosciutto
at the supermarket are
$6, so that's crazy.
What do you think of Italy as
a grocery chain, like quality,
price, and all that?
Is that something that you
find decent all over the world
or is it just marketing?
KATIE: I find the products
at Italy really vary.
When it comes to
prosciutto and things,
there's this really wonderful
family-run salami business,
Salumeria Biellese.
As the name implies, they
are from Biella, originally,
but they're based in like
New Jersey or New York.
So you can find really
awesome stuff there.
I would say when it comes
to cooking or eating
in a Roman spirit, I
don't think you always
have to go to an
Italian source for that.
There are country
hams in Appalachia,
that when you
taste them, they're
like ethereal and
really exquisite.
And they taste
like they could be
from San Daniele or some
really refined prosciutto
maker in Friuli.
Eating everything in
this book is expensive.
So if you want to recreate
those things at home,
grow your own stuff if you can.
There's a whole
resource section that
has different suggestions
on where to find things.
Italy is listed
there but then, also,
Bonne Italia in Chelsea
Market, Formaggio Kitchen,
in Cambridge,
Zingerman's in Michigan.
And know that some things
are worth investing in
and others not so much.
Invest in pasta.
Make pasta the meal.
And it feels so
bad to say this--
buy that $10 packet of pasta,
because the grain that's
in there, the way it's
dried, the way that it's
been conceived is a
vastly different product
than the Barilla packet.
SPEAKER: So you are in town
working on your next cookbook
about Southern Italy.
Can you tell us a
bit more about that?
KATIE: Absolutely, so
the creatively titled,
untitled South
Italy cookbook will
be published by Clarkson
Potter in February 2019.
So we're shooting it very early.
But something that has
been really amazing
is cooking Southern Italian
style in the Bay Area,
where you have these
spectacular tomatoes
and peppers and all sorts
of octopi and sardines
and great things that I
probably couldn't even
find that high quality in
Rome to be quite honest.
So that's been really cool.
The book is 85 recipes and
focuses on the south of Italy,
which I define as the southern
peninsula, excluding Sicily.
There are a lot of
great books on Sicily.
I can recommend some of those.
But my book is going to focus
on Molise, Campania, Basilicata,
Calabria, and Puglia.
And the dishes are mostly
the vanishing, lost,
and disappearing dishes.
Remember when I talked about
all those people escaping
from the economy of the south.
It happened actually
in two phases
in the late 19th, early 20th
century, and then in the 60s.
And that left a lot
of villages vacant.
It left a lot of
farms abandoned.
And so the recipes seek either
to specifically document
a lost dish or a vanishing
dish or traditional dish
or to modify a dish, so that
you'll actually cook it.
So for example,
there's this one dish
that has 16 different
types of beans,
that have to be soaked
separately and cooked
separately and no one
is going to do that--
not anymore, especially
in like a cauldron
in their backyard in
the middle of Mattera--
not going to happen.
But you can cook some things
together, soak some things
together, and then
marry the flavors,
so actually make something
that you'll make at home--
honor these traditions.
That's just one example,
but the cookbook
is supposed to be
like a travel guide
and a document and a cookbook.
And I really am desperate
for all of you guys
to go to South Italy.
It's super amazing
in all the ways.
And its vast, so if
you like archeology,
you've got the whole Bay of
Naples area that's awesome.
If you're into hiking, the
awesome alpinine things.
If you like the sea,
Cilento is super rad.
There's like all
this cool stuff.
So the book will come
out in early 2019,
but I'll be putting out all
sorts of free resources,
so that like--
oh, I really want to eat this
Gallipoli-style sardine dish.
Oh, I know exactly where
to go, where to rent a car,
and what else to do in Gallipoli
based on those free resources.
AUDIENCE: At the
start, you mentioned
that you've also
been exploring some
of the beer culture in Italy.
Can you talk some
more about that?
KATIE: Of course, beer has
ancient roots in Italy.
The Etruscans brewed beer.
And then, there was a
really, really long gap
that the Romans
weren't so into it.
And we really start
to see a rebirth
of beer culture, industrial beer
culture, in the north of Italy
and in Rome, by
the Peroni factory
in the late 19th,
early 20th century.
And for the next
century or so, it's
industrial pilsners, lagers,
and stuff that dominate.
And then, as all
things Italian, there
is this like Genesis story,
which is not totally accurate,
but it is a fun one.
And it states in like 1996, Teo
Musso of the Baladin Brewing
Company founded craft
brewing in Italy.
There already was some
craft brewing going on,
but he's this very
compelling figure
who does not feel limited
by traditional style.
So some of his beers
are like archeo beers,
which study with this
awesome dude, Dr. Pat
McGovern from the
University of Pennsylvania--
the remnants of beer
excavations, fermentation
exclamations from ancient times.
And recreates flavors for
a modern Italian public
based on historical traditions.
There was also, not just Teo
Musso, but also Leonardo da
Vincenzo and all
sorts of brewers--
Birrificio Italiano,
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]..
They're sometimes
style-based, like drawing
from your Northern
European styles
and, sometimes,
ingredient-based.
My favorite brewer, in
fact, uses a lot of fruit
and a lot of wine grapes to give
the beer a sense of terroir.
In Rome, the brew is, by
the way, called Loverbeer.
Which is also the funniest
brewery name ever--
Loverbirra.
So there is this new--
let's say, in 2009
onwards, we see craft beer
is mainstream in Rome.
And that's when Open Baladin
opens in the center of town.
There's already stuff going
on as early as 2001 at
[SPEAKING ITALIAN].
By the way, all of these
places are listed somewhere
in the book.
I know I'm throwing out
a lot of Italian words.
But Rome is the craft beer
consumption capital of Italy.
Milan is a close second.
And it's one of those few
businesses, food or otherwise,
where there is
innovation and creativity
and where it's not exactly
cheap to enter the industry.
But a lot of people
start as home brewers.
They're engineers.
They don't want to
be engineers anymore.
They want to be brewers.
They get some money,
pool resources,
and then open breweries.
So now, we've got well over
1,000 craft breweries in Italy,
including some in the
outskirts of Rome.
And one craft--
well, one brewpub--
it's not a craft pub--
but one brew pub in Prati.
SPEAKER: Thank you so much,
Katie, for joining us.
Such a pleasure.
And thank you all
on the live stream
and those of you attending.
KATIE: Thanks, guys.
[APPLAUSE]